[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paris herzlich willkommen und
guten abend im sport gibt unter anderem
tennis von arbeitnehmern unter von mir
dass die besorgnis ist groß angesichts
der hohen inflation unsere themen
krisengespräch in berlin gewerkschaften
und arbeitgeber beraten mit kanzler
scholz wie verbraucher und wirtschaft
bei steigenden preisen entlastet werden
können
eine welle aus eis und geröll nach dem
gletscher abgang in italien steigt die
zahl der todesopfer der rettungsarbeiten
sind schwierig und
naturwunder weltweit in gefahr wie hier
am great barrier reef sterben die
korallen eine expertenkonferenz in
bremen versucht sie zu rennen
hohe preise darauf müssen wir uns noch
länger einstellen so der kanzler heute
beim treffen mit gewerkschaften
arbeitgebern forschenden unter
bundesbank auftakt der sogenannten
konzertierten aktion das ziel der umgang
mit der hohen inflation dieses land
steht vor der härtesten wirtschafts und
sozialpolitischen krise seit der
wiedervereinigung warnte
arbeitgeber-präsident dulger die
inflationsrate für juni liegt bei 7,6
prozent nach ersten berechnungen des
statistischen bundesamtes preistreiber
nummer eins energie also strom gas
heizöl plus 38 prozent hier sind die
preise förmlich explodiert gegenüber dem
vorjahresmonat ebenfalls deutlich teurer
nahrungsmittel hier ein anstieg von 12,7
prozent über den kampf gegen die
steigenden preise und die besondere
gesprächsrunde heute andreas kruppert
der kanzler hat eingeladen zur
konzertierten aktion die bundesregierung
trifft gewerkschaften arbeitgeber
wirtschaftsexperten das ziel ein
gemeinsam abgestimmtes handeln zur
verabredung der steigenden inflation
einhalt zu geben die konzertierte aktion
erstmals vor 55 jahren ins leben gerufen
1967 die bundesrepublikanische
konjunktur bricht ein
spd-wirtschaftsminister karl schiller
versucht gewerkschaften und arbeitgeber
auf eine rücksichtsvolle gemeinsame lohn
dick zu verpflichten heute gilt es den
explodierenden preisen den kampf
anzusagen und lösungen zu finden wir
stehen vor einer historischen
herausforderung
unsere gesellschaft ist stark viel
stärker als manchmal unterstellt wird
der fairer ausgleich zwischen den
interessen in einem geist der
gemeinsamkeit prägt unser land das
wissen auch arbeitgeber und
gewerkschaften nur gemeinsam kann es
gelingen einkommenseinbußen zu
verhindern es geht allen voran darum
jetzt alles zu unternehmen um eine
rezession zu verhindern standorte zu
stabilisieren wertschöpfungsketten zu
erhalten und beschäftigung zu sichern
das wird in den nächsten monaten schon
schwierig genug es fehlt an fach
arbeitskräften an material an personal
lieferketten sind abgerissen die
betriebe offen zu halten wird eine
herausforderung bleiben die csu fühlt
sich von der bundesregierung
ausgeschlossen bei der suche nach
instrumenten im kampf gegen die
inflation
wenn es zum beispiel auch mal ganz gut
wenn die bundesregierung der opposition
reden würden so eine notlage ja auch
eine konzertierte aktion findet nicht
statt gut zwei stunden konzertierte
aktion im kanzleramt bis zum herbst sind
weitere treffen geplant
theo koll in berlin also hieß heute wir
stehen vor einer historischen
herausforderung das zeigt ja wirklich so
den ernst der lage was sind die
lösungsansätze
also bei dem heutigen ersten treffen
ging es ja noch um die möglichst genaue
beschreibung dieses preis gebirges dass
sich davor bürgern und unternehmern
auftürmt also wie hoch wie steil und wie
gefährlich ist und wird das ganze die
nächsten treffen der konzertierten
aktion die dienen dann dazu möglichst
gemeinsam den weg festzulegen auf dem
niemandem oder wenigen die puste ausgeht
denn schon jetzt gilt ja jeder vierte
haushalt in deutschland als energie arm
muss also über zehn prozent des netto
einkommens für energie ausgeben die
meinungen über den richtigen weg gehen
naturgemäß deutlich auseinander also
muss auf den dramatischen preisanstieg
ein vergleichbarer lohnanstieg folgen
der dann quasi über den inflations berg
hilft oder sorgt dass nur dafür dass die
preise weiter steigen und der berg also
noch steiler wird
diese konzertierte aktion ist er eine
art politischer versuch einer art
gemeinsamer seilschaft und dennoch wird
es am ende darum gehen wer trägt wieviel
von der last einordnung von theo koll
dankeschön
konzert redaktion was genau bedeutet das
eigentlich und was hat sie damals 1967
gebracht informationen dazu finden sie
in der zdf heute
an die inflation ist auch wegen des
ukraine krieges so hoch teile der
ukraine sind zerstört auf das problem
des wiederaufbaus da schauen wir gleich
drauf zuerst blicken wir auf die kämpfe
denn russland versucht weiterhin die
kontrolle über den gesamten donnerstag
das heißt über die region donetsk und
lugansk wenn du hans bis jetzt die
letzte große ukrainische bastion
gefallen christoph des
risikos seit gestern von den russischen
truppen besetzt oder befreit ein
französisches kamerateam ist unterwegs
mit pro russischen soldaten und fragt
nach bei den bewohnern die wenigen die
noch da sind und die sich vor die kamera
trauen sehen es so wie
schrie vor glück als es soweit war und
alle um mich herum denken das gleiche
ich glaube die russen sind so wie ich
und ich bin so wie sie
einzelmeinungen schwer nachzuprüfen fakt
ist mit lissy fans gefällt die gesamte
region luhansk unter russische kontrolle
ein wichtiger etappensieg aus sicht von
präsident putin der verspricht heute
live im fernsehen orden für alle
beteiligten soldaten und sagt sie sollen
sich jetzt definitiv erst einmal
ausruhen und ihre kampfkraft wieder
stärken für alle anderen geht die
mission weiter so wie geplant
vorstoß etwa in richtung slowly 170
kilometer weiter westlich gelegen und
nach ansicht fast aller beobachter die
nächste großstadt die belagert werden
wird wohl wieder c und tödlich für beide
seiten wir können davon ausgehen dass es
im sonntaz keinen schnellen durchmarsch
russischer truppen geben wird sondern
sehr heftige kämpfe um die schwer
bewachten schwer befestigten städte
libyens und klammert
vossloh bilanz gefallen seit gestern
immer mehr bomben drei viertel der
einwohner sollen bereits gefühl nun
seien es droht die nächste phase im
abnutzungskrieg jahre könnte das in der
ukraine so weitergehen glaubt militär
beobachterinnen klein phasen taktischer
ruhe hält sie für denkbar aber wohl nur
damit die besetzer atem holen und ihre
truppen weiter verstärken können
wer angesichts dieser zerstörung ist es
kaum vorstellbar wie die ukraine wieder
aufgebaut werden kann und vor allem wann
im schweizerischen lugano beraten etwa
40 länder und hilfsorganisationen heute
und morgen genau darüber mehrere hundert
milliarden euro wird er wieder auf
baukosten rechnen expertinnen und
experten vor und er kann jetzt zehnte
dauern aber auch über soforthilfe wird
diskutiert und die wird in der ukraine
sehnlichst erwartet zeigt j
die zerstörungen nach vier monaten krieg
sind gewaltig wohnhäuser schulen
verwaltung in den großen orten wie hier
bei kiew läuft schon erste hilfe an aber
weiter nordwestlich im dorf barrymore
steht der tischler boris verloren vor
den trümmern seiner existenz
die fundamente die sind noch da der rest
ist auto motorrad zwei traktoren 62 muss
ich noch
auf schnelle staatliche hilfe kann der
handwerker nicht zählen zu groß ist der
bedarf anderswo im land und auch das
haus der nachbarn wurde beim einmarsch
der russen zerstört eines von vielen
tausenden
wir brauchen geld das wir als rentner
nicht haben um das haus wenigstens für
den winter einigermaßen er zurück
[Musik]
seit kriegsbeginn zielen russische
angriffe immer wieder auch auf
raffinerien und kraftwerken energie wird
knapp und teuer die regierung plant
einen preisstopp für gas und strom vor
dem winter der chef des staatlichen
energieriesen naftogas wie tränke sagt
die speicher seien gefüllt aber man
werde trotzdem zusätzlich gas in europa
einkaufen müssen
wir verhandeln auch mit deutschland über
neue kreditlinien um öl und gas für den
winter einkaufen zu korrosion expertise
und auch hier braucht die ukraine hilfe
wiederaufbauprojekte kommen vielerorts
nur zögerlich voran weil zunächst linien
geräumt werden müssen
ungünstiges wetter vor allem aber rund
eine million kubikmeter eis und fels
nachdem gletscherabbruch in italien
stehen die helfer vor einer wahren
mammut-aufgabe mindestens 13 menschen
werden noch vermisst sieben tote sind
bestätigt das unglücksgebiet liegt in
den dolomiten einem teilgebiet der
italienischen alpen höchster gipfel ist
das gut 3300 meter hohen marmolada
massiv an deren nordflanke der
betroffene gletscher liegt über die lage
dort berichtet annette helfen wenn es
ist eine lawine aus eis schnee und
felsbrocken die berger prast nachdem ein
teil des marula gletschers ab bricht sie
reißt alles mit sich auch zwei
bergsteiger gruppen die bergretter
müssen mehrere tote bergen angehörige
kommen heute um sie zu identifizieren
diesen eltern hatte der sohn von
gletschern noch ein foto gesendet kurz
bevor die lawine erfasste von der mama
und papa trophy eine mutter hat ihren
sohn verloren
und dann auch noch die zwei besten
freunde es ist hart
leider
bottrop
verletzte werden in umliegende
krankenhäuser geflogen unter ihnen ein
mann und eine frau aus deutschland
die steine und eislawine hat opfer
hunderte meter mitgerissen sie zu
identifizieren ist den bergrettern kaum
möglich mehrere menschen werden noch
vermisst und erwähnt der katastrophe
oder einer solchen katastrophe mit
solchen unglaublichen massen die
hoffnung noch menschen lebend zu finden
liegt ehrlich gesagt fast 1 0 unterwegs
sein der gletscher brocken brach ab
nachdem hier seit einigen wochen
ungewöhnlich hohe temperaturen
herrschten am berg marmolada wurde
gestern der rekordwert von 10 grad
gemessen solche ereignisse könnten wohl
künftig häufig auftreten als folge des
klimawandels diese normale die tombola
zum beispiel ist nicht bekannt dass eine
hochrisiko route und das ist finde ich
das überraschende daran was sich mit dem
klimawandel weiter verstärken wird
glaube ich dass wir reden mehr
potenzielle gefahrenstellen sehen werden
im hochgebirge heute regnete es zunächst
inzwischen arbeiten die retter wieder
laut behörden könnte es noch wochen
dauern bis alle opfer gefunden und
geborgen sind
nach dem amoklauf gestern in der
dänischen hauptstadt kopenhagen wurde
der 22 jährige mutmaßliche täter heute
in eine geschlossene psychiatrische
klinik eingewiesen nach einem
terroristischen motiv sieht es nicht aus
teilte die polizei mit am abend soll es
für die opfer in der nähe des tatortes
eine gedenkfeier geben michael kruse
berichtet
blumen für die vielen opfer drei tote
darunter zwei teenagern 30 verletzte
vier davon schwer so die bilanz des
amoklaufs im kopenhagener
einkaufszentrum das entsetzen ist auch
am tag danach riesig es so schlimm alle
liefen aus der shopping mall meine
tochter mein schwiegersohn mein
enkelkind waren da noch drin das waren
bange minuten bis er wieder zu hause
waren wir sind einfach losgelaufen in
panik ohne zu wissen was los war eine
hatte schüsse gehört
gestern am frühen abend gingen die
ersten notrufe ein handy aufnahmen
zeigen menschen die aus dem
einkaufszentrum fliegen der
tatverdächtige konnte schnell vor ort
festgenommen werden ein 22-jähriger denn
in der laut polizei als psychisch
auffällig bekannt war er hatte ein
gewehr und ein messer bei sich posierte
mit waffen in den sozialen medien zu
motiv und hintergründe tat will sich die
polizei noch nicht äußern
es ist mir sehr wichtig festzustellen
dass nach den ermittlungen der
vergangenen nacht nichts darauf
hindeutet dass der verdächtige mit
anderen personen zusammengearbeitet hat
oder hilfe von anderen bekommen hat
auch die dänische ministerpräsidentin
besuchte am nachmittag den tatort
mein aller größtes mitgefühl gilt den
opfern den familien den angehörigen
und all denen die gestern die
schlimmsten minuten oder stunden in
ihrem leben durchmachen muss
inzwischen hat eine richterin
untersuchungshaft für den
tatverdächtigen angeordnet die soll der
22 jährige in einer geschlossenen
psychiatrischen klinik verbringen
in den usa ist heute nationalfeiertag
gefeiert wird das mit paraden im ganzen
land in chicago hat es vor einer stunde
schüsse gegeben auf solch einer parade
die situation ist unübersichtlich der
tatort weiträumig abgesperrt laut
mehrerer medien soll es tote gegeben
haben erste bilder zeigen offenen
menschen auf der flucht vor allem
schützen
er sei von einem dach aus auf menschen
geschossen haben weitere informationen
gibt es bislang nicht
mit dem australischen winter machen
derzeit außergewöhnlich starke
regenfälle den menschen immer größere
sorgen vor allem an der ostküste
besonders dramatisch ist die lage im
großraum sydney mehrere zehntausend
menschen wurden aufgerufen ihre häuser
zu verlassen oder sich auf eine flucht
vorzubereiten
vielfach unterstützen soldaten die
arbeit der behörden und helferinnen
inzwischen ist der größte staudamm
sydneys übergelaufen
mit sorge und wehmut blicken die
menschen in australien auch auf die
korallenriffe vor ihren küsten seit
menschengedenken war das great barrier
reef eines der artenreichsten ökosysteme
weltweit dass es auch eines der
empfindlichsten ist wurde deutlich mit
dem anstieg der meerestemperatur und der
zunehmenden wasserverschmutzung eine
konferenz in bremen sucht wege das
massenhafte korallen sterben weltweit zu
stoppen kai niklasch
drei korallenbleiche in den letzten fünf
jahren haben dem great barrier reef vor
australien zugesetzt gleichen sinn
stressreaktionen die zum absterben der
korallen führen können der natürliche
küstenschutz des 25 millionen jahre
alten naturwunders bröckelt früher war
das meist nur der norden jetzt betrifft
das auch die zentralen und südlichen
teil und das ist ein riesenproblem weil
die riffe die ja sicher strecken über
über 2000 kilometer nahezu alle
betroffen sind und fast keine zeit haben
um sich von der letzten gleich zu
erholen bevor die nächste blase wieder
kommt erstmals in europa welt
korallenriff konferenz in bremen einer
der teilnehmer fürst albert von monaco
der sich seit jahren für den schutz der
weltmeere einsetzt die botschaft der
korallenriffe konferenz jetzt den
klimawandel stoppen ansonsten seien im
jahr 2030 90 prozent der korallenriffe
unwiederbringlich verloren
wir müssen gleichzeitig den klimawandel
entschärfen alle lokalen stressfaktoren
wie überfischung und verschmutzung
reduzieren und neue technologie
entwickeln um wieder aufzuforsten und zu
schützen
obwohl korallen noch leichen
funktioniert häufig die befruchtung
nicht mehr daher gibt es bereits
zahlreiche programme in den taucher
erschaffen korallen künstlich wieder
anzusiedeln das ist nicht die ultimative
lösung wenn man so viel ich am
klimaschutz arbeiten wir setzen an der
geschlechtlichen fortpflanzung von
korallen an das heißt wir unterstützen
die fortpflanzung die an vielen vielen
orten in der welt vor allen dingen in
der karibik nicht mehr erfolgreich ist
doch voraussetzung bleibt dass vor allem
der temperaturanstieg von luft und
wasser gestoppt wird und
zum tennisturnier in wimbledon norbert
dann läuft's ja das deutsche erfolgs
doppel männer ja das erste mal dass
kevin krawietz und andreas mies das
viertelfinale bei diesen rasen klassiker
in london erreicht haben starker
auftritt des deutschen duos das gegen
gionis o'meara und kennt ski aus
großbritannien glatt mit 13 0 sätzen
gewann
trotzdem gab es gegenwehr bei dieser
hochklassigen doppel begegnung das
deutsche duo gewinnt gegen die briten
jonny und kens gab es die mit 7 zu 6 6
zu 4 und 6 zu 4 habe zum niesen tin
wimmelten zuvor bislang nicht über die
dritte runde hinausgekommen mit starken
aufschlägen gut platzierten returns und
einem insgesamt aggressiven auftreten
kommen sie relativ ungefährdet zu musik
und dem erstmaligen einzug ins
viertelfinale die zweimaligen french
open sieger treffen nun auf das an
nummer zwei gesetzte kroatische doppel
mctavish
teamhotel erkundet trainingsplätze
getestet die deutsche frauenfußball
nationalmannschaft bereitet sich in
london auf ihr erstes em spiel am
freitag gegen dänemark vor erstes ziel
der dfb kickerinnen drei punkte zum
start ins turnier im wunderschönen sein
park in der residenzstadt des duke of
northumberland hat die deutsche
delegation quartier genommen 23
spielerinnen und das team dahinter in
isleworth in der idyllischen
einflugschneise des größten londoner
flughafens der lärm aber stört sie nicht
ich glaube wir sind auf alles
vorbereitet und das wird uns nicht von
unserer leistung abbringen linda
dallmann zuletzt torschütze nach einem
prima spiel zu das 7 0 gegen die schweiz
ideal fürs deutsche selbstbewusstsein
wir haben alle riesenlust und freuen uns
dass endlich los geht es am freitag
gegen dänemark live bei uns im zdf
in viereinhalb monaten start der fußball
wm in katar bei der anhörung heute im
deutschen bundestag da hagelte es kritik
menschenrechtsorganisationen
kritisierten die anhaltung der
verletzung der grundrechte und
ausbeutung von arbeitsmigranten auf den
wm baustellen dfb-generalsekretär in
ulrich kündigte an dass die europäischen
mannschaften deshalb so hört nicht beim
turnier zeichen setzen dann
sind wir gespannt für diese zeichen denn
konkret aussehen werden
wann haben sie das letzte mal im brief
geschrieben der siebenjährige niklas aus
bayern gibt einen guten grund mal wieder
zu papier und stift zu greifen denn er
hat diese blumenwiese gemalt die ein
junger für insekten angelegt hat jeder
vierte der 18.000 teilnehmer am
online-voting der post von niklas motiv
für die neue 85 cent marke am schönsten
und im postamt gibt es sie ab donnerstag
und wenn sie nicht wissen was sie
schreiben sollen über das wetter kann
man sich immer aus lassen morgen ist es
oft freundlich nur ganz im norden und an
den alpen schauer und gewitter genau
erfahren sie es gleich von christa haben
das heute schon mal können sie um 21 45
sehen mit christian sieh was und morgen
begrüßt sie an dieser stelle barbara
hahlweg wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das azorenhoch streckt seine
fühler mit ruhigem und warmem wetter
nach uns aus aber diese kaltfront hier
im süden und ein tiefausläufer im norden
macht das wetter dann doch ein bisschen
interessanter und so haben wir heute
nacht im norden noch ein paar mehr
wolken vor allem aber südlich der donau
schauer und einzelne teils kräftige
gewitter dazwischen ist es oft klar und
sie kennen das wenn der himmel aufklart
kühlt es ab morgens teils nur auf acht
grad unter den wolken es ist mit 16 grad
milder morgen haben wir dann in der
mitte und im süden wieder einen warmen
bis heißen tag für uns mit 25 bis 30
grad am oberrhein an den alpen und im
norden ist es mit 19 bis 23 grad aber
ein bisschen kühler zum einen sind im
norden ein paar mehr wolken unterwegs
wir haben in frischem westwind und auch
einige schauer im küstenumfeld in
südbayern sind ebenfalls schauer und
einzelne gewitter unterwegs die sich im
tagesverlauf dann aber in die alpen
zurückziehen ja und dazwischen mal mehr
quellwolken mal mehr sonne der rest der
woche der ist nicht mehr ganz so heiß
aber trotzdem noch angenehm mit 19 bis
26 grad mittwochs kommt abends von
nordwesten etwas regen auf der sich am
donnerstag dann in die südosthälfte des
landes liegt am freitag ist das schon
wieder trocken tschüss